of award-winning professional male  stripping all you've got is your moves  and balls  literally ladies we hammer stripping is  a respectable profession  [Music]  when a jackhammer poster now my engines  been trying to get me through these  doors my budget rain we're all feeling  stage one six years of scotch won't peel  a champion 94 to 97 we got here we got  Mario Luigi and Latina street trash Jack  White's batter brother and The  Situation's more steroid up its brother  I'm gonna miss her safety  Jules Judy George erotic are one of the  most powerful casting agents in the  world all we gotta do is get some  agreement in balls of him  i sponsored you for one strip off women  now you're a few years and death you  know most people may not much money I  cut off the fall time's up  I'm at the liquor store slang in my CDs  clackum the jeans Luther page have  exactly where this Russian sausage of  this beat boyfriend your problems you  wish you had big one of these